- [Voiceover] What is
the measure of angle EAC?
So we have this symbol
here, which means angle,
and then these three letters, EAC.
Now to measure angle EAC, we need to first
find angle EAC down here on our picture,
and the way we can do that
is use these three letters
and we're gonna go in the
order that they're given to us.
So the first letter we're told is E,
so the first letter we'll
find down here is E.
From there, we'll go to
the second letter, A.
And then finally, we go
to our last letter, C.
Again, in the order that
they were told to us.
So this opening right here is our angle.
We wanna know how many
degrees is this opening?
The most common way to measure an angle
would be to use a protractor,
but we're not given a protractor,
so we can't do that, but we
do have enough information
on this diagram down here to solve this.
What we can see is that
our large angle EAC
is made up of two smaller angles.
This first one, angle EAD.
Right here, angle EAD...
plus from there, it
picks up with angle DAC.
Angle DAC.
These two angles, this
first one from here to here,
and then the second from here to here,
when they're combined,
they make the same size
opening as our angle.
So if we can combine these two angles,
we will know the measure of our angle
because again, these two combined
are equal to our entire angle.
So let's do that, starting with EAD,
we can see we're told, it's 60 degrees.
That's a 60 degree opening.
Plus angle DAC has a 75 degree opening,
and so if we combine that,
if we go 60 degrees to here
plus another 75 down to here,
we've covered our entire angle.
Our entire opening in 60 plus another 75.
So we can add these to solve
for the measure of our angle.
Six tens plus seven
tens is 13 tens or 130.
13 and then that zero is there
because we're talking about tens.
Plus zero ones and five ones is five ones.
And so 130 plus five is 135 degrees.
So the measure of our
entire angle, angle EAC
is 135 degrees.